el dolor aún es insoportable en texas
con una habilidad fueron recordados los
19 estudiantes y las dos maestras que
perdieron la vida como consecuencia de
un nuevo tiroteo masivo global de pero
hay un sentimiento común tras la
tragedia
esto tiene que cambiar tenemos que hacer
justicia para estos niños este mundo no
es buen lugar para que crezcan los niños
y que las cosas tienen que cambiar
en
vela recuerda a su amiga él y garcía una
de las víctimas del tiroteo como una
niña amable activa y llena de confianza
la misma confianza que tras lo ocurrido
ella ha perdido a veces la invade el
pánico
y también
disminuir en público
a veces con de un auto muy parece un
poco sospechoso me asusté cuando escucho
regalos pero trato de estar bien los
llamados a la acción se enfocan en la
figura de joe biden el presidente visitó
la dolida localidad texana para consolar
y para prometer acciones para enfrentar
al poderoso gobierno mentís tico
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sin embargo imponer límites a las normas
que permiten el fácil acceso a las armas
de guerra ha sido misión imposible para
washington
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la misma semana en la que se llevó a
cabo el tiroteo la asociación nacional
del rifle en el rey mostró músculo y
celebró por todo lo alto su convención
anual
justamente in texas
allí personalidades como el ex
presidente de donald trump defendieron
el derecho a poseer y portar armas que
garantiza la segunda enmienda de la
constitución
la rabia y la impotencia de los
habitantes se ve también reflejada en el
lento actuar de la policía durante el
ataque sus acciones serán investigadas
por el departamento de justicia igual de
una comunidad más enlutado para siempre
por la violencia armada y angustiada por
la urgencia de un cambio que nadie sabe
si de la mano de los políticos llegará